Michal Segalov, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thanks for having me.
So great to have you.
Software Engineering Director
at Google.
Co-founder of the amazing program
Mind The Gap.
But I don't wanna talk about Google.
I don't wanna talk about
what's happening today.
I wanna go back.
I wanna hear your story
because it's such an incredible inspiration
for me when I first heard it
a few months ago
when we had coffee back
when you were allowed to have coffee
with another person in the same room
and not over Zoom.
Michal, take me away to your childhood.
How do you enter the engineering world?
So I think the story of how I got
into engineering and computer science
is kind of a story of
lucky or unlucky coincidences
depending on how you look at it.
And it's all been
kind of happening by chance.
So, growing up,
I was always exposed to computers
in the sense that I had two older brothers
and they were very much
into computer science.
But my exposure was,
I would say, almost negative.
I was very adamant and very convinced
on one thing:
that there is absolutely no way
that I would go into computer science.
I looked at it as this geeky,
and programming in general
right,
I looked at it as this geeky thing
that my older brothers are doing
and there was no way that someone
as cool as me at the time
would ever be interested in.
And I think that it was something that
I was very,
it was very much a part of
how I thought about it.
In fact, there is even stories
that run in my family about that time
where everyone tried
to teach me how to program.
And there was really a family effort
where my brothers
and my parents all kind
of gave it their own shot and
at different times reached
pretty much the same conclusion
that computer science and programming
is just not for me.
And is that just
because you're not enjoying it?
You're not willing to try it out?
Why did you reach that conclusion?
Or why did everybody else
reach that conclusion?
So, I actually interviewed them
not too long ago and asked them about it.
And I think that they,
of course, retroactively, they all gave
slightly different things than
I think what they thought
at the time.
But it was a mix of what they perceived
as lack of interest
and, at best, and maybe lack of skill
if you look at some of how they perceived
our interactions around computer science
and programming at the time.
So, I think that from my perspective,
and I think I kind of suppressed
that whole experience
because I didn't remember it as well
as they all did.
But I think kind of reflecting back,
I just didn't think of it as something
that would make sense for me to do
and I didn't really understand
what programming is
and what programming
essentially enables in my life
and in general.
So, I kind of took it for what it was,
which was okay
you type things in the computer
and then it spits out numbers
at you or does something at you.
And I didn't quite make that connection.
And I think the other component
is that I didn't even perceive myself
as the type of person
that could potentially do this, right.
The only people who I knew
that were programming at the time
were basically my two older brothers
or my two geeky older brothers. Right?
Right.
It wasn't something that I felt
very connected to.
And what ultimately did
clearly change things for me,
because obviously things have changed,
was actually the military.
So, I was born and raised in Israel
and of course, when you're 18 there's
a mandatory military service.
And one thing that the militarism
does very well
is utilize all of its possible resources.
And basically, they ran me through
a series of tests
at the end of which they decided that
computer programming is something
that I can potentially be quite good at.
So, different from your brothers
and your parents,
they don't ask you
and come up with a conclusion.
... they tell you,
"Michal, for the next three years,
you're gonna be a computer programmer."
Exactly. I even remember
that they asked me.
There was an in-person interview.
They asked me, "Would you be interested in that?"
And I said, "No."
For me, the military takes
your input into consideration
but ultimately that's what's
best for the military.
Right.
And that's kind of how I,
I guess, discovered this.
So, you become a software engineer.
Fast forward a few years
and you're already
you're a very, very successful
software engineer within Google.
A director within Google.
But looking back in retrospective,
So obviously you love
what you're doing.
I mean, you're a geek.
We can say now, proudly.
I am. I'm proud of it.
But Michal, going back to your childhood,
that was something that
you weren't really willing to accept.
And I think that I actually
can relate very very well
to what you're saying.
The first lines of code that
I really wrote were in the military.
And even though I come from a very techie,
and geeky household
I was never really into
computer programming.
Now, I love programming
both at Stanford and at Hippo
where I work and also in the IDF.
Why do you think that you weren't
interested in computer science?
Or why weren't you open to exploring
it back when you were a kid?
So I think the thing that my story,
when I reflect back,
when I think of it,
is that success and being successful
at something is very situational.
Right.
And it's something that as a leader
is important for me to remember.
It's not that someone is
not good at something. Right?
Oftentimes, if that someone hasn't been
exposed to something in the right way,
that just makes things click.
Or sometimes it's that someone, that people
don't perceive themselves
as being able to excel at something.
And I think that in my case,
it was probably a combination where
I both didn't perceived myself
as someone who could do
this line of work.
But also I think it just
it might not have been the right time
or the right way to introduce me
into computer science.
And I was actually quite shocked
because when I talked to my brother,
who probably was the one
who was able to persevere along with
his attempts to try
and teach me very basic
computer science concepts,
the things that he said
that I didn't grasp at the time
are things that are quite trivial, right.
So I think it was more of a matter of
me being open to it
and also, how it was taught.
And somehow when I was
18 and in the military,
something just clicked.
And from there on it just kind of flowed.
I mean it resonates a lot with
a very interesting conversation I had
with another leader the other day
where they were talking about how,
when you're managing somebody
and they're not living up to their potential
by keeping them on the team
and by not giving them concrete feedback
or sometimes firing them when you need to,
you're actually doing a disservice to them
because you're not allowing them
to live up to the potential.
And maybe it's situational
that in the current place where they're at,
they're not able to do that.
Maybe they do have the skills,
but they're just not able to explore them
and to bring them to fruition.
But Michal,
you're taking your own experience
and then you did something
really amazing with it.
And you helped create an organization
called Mind the Gap.
So, tell me a little bit about what that is
and how that helped inspire other girls
to go into tech?
So, Mind The Gap is a program
that I started with Daniela Reichman,
who's also an engineering manager at Google
and is a close friend of mine.
We started it, I think it was in 2009
so quote some time ago,
with a goal of exposing young girls
to computer science and ...
And I think we took a pretty, I would say,
self centered point of view on things.
And we both had quite similar stories
of how we got into programming
and of being resistant to it
at that critical age.
And we basically wanted
to create something
that would cater to our younger selves
and try to expose our younger selves
to computer science programming
and show us what we see in it today.
Right. What is the younger self?
So, what age are we talking about
which is really the critical age
that you've understood is where
you should inject yourself in?
So, it's around junior high school.
The reason we chose that age is because
if you look at the funnel of when
girls and minorities drop out of I would say
the path towards computer science,
that's around the time that it happens.
In Israel it seems particularly pronounced
because all the AP classes,
the selection of what you do your APs
in basically happens at that time.
Right. Because so in Israel,
differently than in a lot of other
places, especially the US,
you actually choose a profession
back already in high school
or you choose what is your specialization.
And Israel is very well known with that. Right?
That very early on, you have to sort
of choose what is your path.
And oftentimes after the army
and after you usually go to India
or South America,
you rediscover your roots
and what you wanna do.
Okay. So interesting.
So, you go in and what do you actually do
with these young women
and what impact does this have?
So, we basically try to think of
what are the main causes that
create this drop.
And I think much like
the story that I told about myself,
it's a mix of things.
So, one is many of them
just don't understand
what computer science is.
It seems as, there's like code thing
where you do something at the computer
all by yourself and something happens
and it doesn't really relate
to our day to day lives.
It's perceived as a profession
that is very solitary
where you don't actually work
with ... people
and you don't have to leverage
any people skills that you might have.
And finally, there aren't enough,
unfortunately, role models.
So, even if you know
what computer science is,
you don't not necessarily think of yourself
as someone who could go in that path
just because you don't see yourself
in the people who are successful.
So, it's almost like a chicken
and the egg problem
because, yeah. Self-explanatory.
Yeah. So, we basically started
office visits at the Google office
where initially,
they were on a monthly basis,
later on a weekly basis,
where we would bring in
a group of girls.
And we would give them a lecture, a
technical talk about computer science.
And the way that we tailored it
is very much explaining how
computer science
touches our day to day lives. Right?
Computer science is everywhere.
It's in our phones.
It's in our cars.
It's all around us.
So, creating that connection
and making them see the impact
that they could have
on people's lives
via computer science
is one very important thing.
Then we also had a panel
where we brought in different types
of disciplines under computer science.
The computer science or
engineering umbrella.
There's product management,
software engineering.
There is UX, user experience, research,
and many many other things
just to show the diversity
of skills that one might need
or might be able to leverage
when going down that path.
Now Michal, I have to say that
I relate so much to what you're saying
because just like this,
I was under the same impression
going through high school and
I took AP Computer Science.
I knew Java
I knew whatever,
but I still thought that, yes,
it's just about writing code.
There is no relationship to the real life.
And honestly,
it's also because the curriculum
in school it's in a cube.
You don't really understand
the connection to computers outside.
You learn the algorithms
and you learn the math,
but you don't learn
how it impacts you.
Now, you mean in 2020, literally,
almost everything in the room here
has an operating system.
Everything has a brain.
And I consider myself a product guy.
I consider myself as
someone who loves people.
I love user experience.
But because I have this knowledge
of computer science,
I'm able to actually think
about what products
I could potentially build.
And I'm so thankful that I got,
that the Army pushed me to learning this.
And that's why I can relate so well
to what you're saying
because as a high schooler
and in middle school,
it's so hard to understand this.
It's, so basically the way I think
of programming, it's a tool
that gives you this magical ability
to build the things
that could change people's lives.
And this is what Mind the Gap is about.
Showing that to younger girls.
And the program has been going on
for 10 years,
just over 10 years now.
There's about five thousand girls a year
that go through it.
Five thousand girls a year?
Oh, my.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
So, it's basically,
I hope, the next generations
of women computer scientists
will go through it.
And it keeps evolving it keeps changing
based on feedback that we get
and things that we see are working
and are not working.
And I should say that Daniela and I
are no longer actively running the program.
There's basically a new generation
of amazing leaders that are
doing this wonderful, wonderful work.
And I think that's a part
of what I quite like about it.
The fact that it's not built
around Daniela or around me.
It's built around the actual content.
And I think that's a huge vote of confidence
that you have this inspiration for others
to continue with it.
And five thousand girls a year,
that's just incredible.
Okay. And, you know,
before we started this
we were talking a little bit about
a personal board of directors.
I think that's a fascinating term.
I can't wait to hear what it means.
So, when I reflect on my career
and things that have helped me most.
The thing that I think
is most pronounced in my career
is what I call this
"personal board of directors" Right
So, it's a set of people who are my mentors.
And much like a board of directors
we meet regularly.
I take their advice, or I listen to their advice
right ultimately, it's up to me.
We're all vested together in this thing called
each other's success, right
It's very much a mutual relationship.
And I think that it helps me a lot
because oftentimes just hearing
someone else's perspective on things
is quite valuable.
And these people, a lot of them
have been with me for a decade now
now or even more, right.
So, they know me, sometimes,
even maybe better than I know myself.
Right.
So, having them say certain things
is something that
more often than you'd expect,
actually, makes me change my mind
or see things differently.
Amazing.
And I think it started
actually when the group of women
that were doing Mind the Gap,
initially where we would meet for
Mind The Gap reasons or whatnot
and overtime basically
we built this community
...
I'm a mother of two very cute kids.
Yeah, we can cut that out if we need to.
You know, it's very cute.
So maybe I'll start with the board of directors question again?
So, most people when they
think of board of directors,
they think of people who come in
and they have power over your organization
or over your work.
They have, your voting a lot.
You have to please them.
What it sounds to me is that
you formed these group of mentors
that you deeply respect
and they respect you
and they're not voting on anything
and you're not trying to please them,
but they are people
who are following your journey.
And when you say that they're invested
in this, it means that they've
invested in the relationship. Right?
They believe you.
And they love working with you
or they love helping you
achieve your potential.
Yeah. It's basically that.
And oftentimes the people who I've worked with
in the past -
No problem.
So, yeah, it is very much that
it's people who oftentimes
have either worked with
or have met professionally otherwise.
And there's always something
that I deeply respect
and want to learn from them.
Right.
And we tried to,
I would hope that it's also mutual
and there's something that some of them
would want to learn from me.
But it's definitely focused about the thing
that I admire about this person,
the thing I wanna get their opinion on.
I love it.
Michael, I wanna go up 30,000 feet in the air
and I wanna look as an overview
of what's happening today in the space.
We can go on things like Mind the Gap
or we can talk about
different experiences you have.
But what are some of the biggest challenges
you think that we're facing now
in the industry with computer science,
whether that's on the education perspective
or the personal fulfillment perspective.
Because now you're a leader,
you're managing quite a few people
within a large organization like Google.
You've gone through this whole experience
yourself with mentors.
And I'd love to pick your brain
over the next few minutes.
What are the biggest challenges
and what can I take with me
as a young engineer,
as a young entrepreneur,
and keeping in mind for the future?
So, first I think that focus
is one of the things that pretty much
reshape and got a lot of leaders,
myself included,
to rethink things that
...
The ability to talk to your peers
face to face or to meet people
and how to create this.
It's effectively a new leadership style
where you find yourselves
talking to a computer, to a camera
and you might not even see all the people
that you're talking to.
So, it's very different
than what we're used to
and how to adjust running an organization
where people have lives
people have kids.
And where do you create that boundary?
Where we work and live
in the same place right now.
So, when is work? When is life?
How do you mix the two?
So I think that is definitely something that
I don't have a good answer on just yet,
but it's definitely something
that I'm thinking of.
And how should I adapt
my leadership style.
I mean it sounds like something
almost every manager in the world now
has to adapt to
because nobody really
experienced this before.
This magnitude of lack of work life balance,
when the sofa is both work and your sofa
And different people, of course,
are impacted differently.
If you think of parents,
they're probably a population
that has a much more difficult time
and their challenges are quite different
than maybe someone
who lives on their own
and maybe even social distancing is
more difficult than that person.
So, I think each person has
very different needs.
And it's important for leaders
and organizations to think of that,
take that into consideration
and not necessarily expect,
it's not a mold that you can apply,
or that every person can apply.
Michal, what are you most excited about
in computer science?
In the industry?
The field that I work on,
which is natural language understanding
and I view as something
that I am personally very excited about.
I think that it's an area that's
been evolving very rapidly.
If you think like ...
and basically you see these abilities
that maybe years ago
seemed like science fiction
or something that,
think of the Turing test as an example, right?
I think you are supposed to recognize
whether or not a person is speaking to you
or a computer
Right.
And I think that the advancements
that were made are quite impressive
state-of-the-art advancements,
and I think that now
we're starting to see those
basically being built at scale
by a lot of the larger companies,
like Google being one of them.
So that's an area
that I think will keep evolving.
And I think that we will see
more applications on products
of the technology that we know is there.
And I think that the challenge
there is two-fold.
So, one is finding the right set of products
and how to leverage that in a way
that's engaging on the one hand
and doesn't have the creepy element
let's say on the other hand. Right?
And on the other hand,
I think a very big technical challenge
of how to apply these algorithms at scale.
When you think of the scale that
a product like Google and some of the others
ones need it.
So for me, I think that applies
for a very wide set of challenges.
I think it's fascinating that you get
to build products and work on technologies
that at the end they impact immediately.
Hundreds of millions of customers.
It's something that I think
any engineer can only dream of
getting to really having
a production code run and
impact the lives of so many people.
And I think that's probably the most
incredible motivation you can have
for building great products
because I know that a lot of people
are passionate for algorithms
for the sake of algorithms.
You know, I know about myself.
I'm passionate about impact
and how to use technologies
and deep technologies to impact
the lives of people.
I think what you're doing
there is just incredible.
Michal, before we leave,
I have to put you on the spot
one last time.
And I need three words that you
would use to describe yourself.
Three words. Wow. Engineer.
The hardest question.
but already know the answer.
Okay, engineer.
Persistent.
Mother.
Engineer, persistent, mother.
It sounds like -
Not necessarily in that order
I love it.
Michal, thank you very much.
Toda raba
and best of luck through
these difficult times.
Thank you.
It was great.
Thanks for having me.
Take care.
Bye bye.
Bye.